see if I tell you this movies good is it
a January movie or is it a December
movie this Studios man why don't they
just release December movies in December
and January movies in January I'm
getting it late irritates me American
sniper so American snipers directed by
Clint Eastwood his stars Bradley Cooper
it's a true story of this guy who's just
a really absurdly good shot with a rifle
so he joins the military and 9/11
happens he's like I need to go over
there and fight because you know honor
and Duty is one of those guys just wants
to take out baggy credit it reminds me
of Bruce Wayne I'm gonna quote the
Burton Batman it's just a line from
there it's also been in the comic box
where it's like why are you doing this
and he's like cuz no one else can no one
else wills my responsibility to do it
what kinda shows his mindset of why he
does what he does and it's just the
story of this guy and what I liked about
this movie is it didn't glorify war it
wasn't like are you honored medals and
how awesome is that yeah we're good shot
in Sniper America merica merica this guy
is staples the deadliest sniper in US
military history this guy has the most
kills as a sniper of anybody so coulda
just glorify the [ __ ] out of that but
ultimately what this movie did really
well is show that it's just ugly and
it's difficult and it takes a toll on a
person you see that a lot of the
trailers the first trailer I saw this
movie I love la that is the most intense
trailer ever it's the kid he's running
with the pipe bomb it's like I think I'm
pretty sure that's a pipe bomb do I
shoot him or do I not he's gonna kill
like 20 soldiers I kid 20 soldiers it's
just those decisions are in this moving
I like to sing that but again as the
movie's going on it shows it's just
weighing down on him because I don't
care who you are you cannot go to war
pull the trigger have someone across
from you die and have it not take a toll
on you just take a chunk out of you it
does if you say it doesn't if you're
like I did it it didn't in ten years
you're gonna be like ah [ __ ] Jeremy was
right now I'm coming to terms with it
yeah every time this guy comes home he
just volunteers to go back on tour
because it's what he knows out there the
more he does it the more strain it puts
and the more he loses himself it's just
as references downward spiral among all
the books and the glory there's this
really dark hidden story of this dude
who's damaged and really glad Clint
Eastwood could bring that to us
all ten years ago someone's like hey
Clint Eastwood's making this movie
without a doubt I would have been like
awesome it's gonna be great I'm gonna go
see it but now American snipers at Clint
Eastwood has you know range of movies
some good some bad I was like well it's
either gonna be really good or boring as
[ __ ] luckily this is the really good
category because it was really well done
it was really good Bradley Cooper also
this dude continues to impress me more
and more I'm really glad that the dude
who was one of the clowns in The
Hangover has really good dramatic acting
chops like this guy is gonna stick
around for many years to come many
decades even his wife in the movie I was
like where have I seen her Sienna Miller
where have I see only [ __ ]
she was the Baroness from GI Joe GI just
another thing entirely can't really
judge Jeremy Irons on Dungeons & Dragons
alone same thing with her now this girl
was really good it was just she did a
really good job at displaying the strain
that this lifestyle is putting on her
and she wants to break through she wants
to reach out she wants to have a
marriage with her husband again this
movie has more than a few intent seems
to not just the whole like oh should I
shoot him should I not you know is that
a point this guy's just getting his
groove and he's taking guys out you're
like right this could get a little
boring but no there are some nail-biting
seasons almost like pockets of scenes
that reminded me of Black Hawk Down a
bit the movie was lovely when you're
sitting down to this movie you got to
know you are here for an investment a
Clint Eastwood war epic about drama and
one guy's emotional damage in
post-traumatic stress and there you go
not for the faint of heart it's not for
people who take this stuff lightly but
it was a really well directed movie a
really well acted movie there were
layers to and it brought humanity to the
soldier and the legend I call him the
legend in the movie so right there I
feel like Clint Eastwood was like okay
his nickname is the legend we're gonna
bring that down to humanity he did a
really good job that would have been
just easy to skate by on the legend
alone in the end I will say American
sniper is definitely worth buying on
blu-ray right so American sniper have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you